test if you're just starting the
business we were trying to launch into a
new initiative make sure you test
everything before you expand it'll give
you the best chance of being successful
because I don't want you going out
taking out a huge loan putting all your
savings into making this company and it
not working out and you're in debt for
the rescue of life paying this off for
that one mistake test sings on a small
scale make sure it works and then expand
from there I got a question from a
YouTube viewer mo I love momo's got this
great smiles always posting and all my
videos thank you mow and moe wrote in to
say Evan which do you think is more
beneficial or storefront which gives me
instant gratification or an online store
both of them can work it's just a matter
of testing I would start by thinking
where do your skills line up better have
you ever been in an online store do you
have any experience with online
development or have you ever worked at a
retail location do you have any
experience that will help you there
whichever one you pick start small it's
great to have the big vision I want that
for you you should have a big dream for
your company but start small and test
see you if it works so if I'm looking at
that online store doesn't cost a lot to
set up set it up simple don't spend a
ton of money on and start promoting it
and see if you get some results see if
you like it see if it works for the
store it can be really expensive start
in the store and retail stores are one
of the highest failure rates of any
business to start it costs a ton of
money so the way to start small is to
open up a little mini store within an
existing one find the company that is
related to what you're selling and find
a way to partner up with them if you're
a hairstylist that's your dream to be a
great hair stylist instead of open up
your own hair salon which is going to
cost tons of money find a related
business maybe a nail salon and ask if
you can rent a spot from them maybe it's
permanent a permanent little spot or
maybe it's only once a week just
something to test it out see
footwork see if you like it see if
you're making money so if you want to
expand it if you don't if it doesn't
work you're not out huge amounts of
money so both of these can work I'd see
word of your skills lineup better and
start testing small as you go this thing
up for everybody watching there's a
three-step process to make sure that
this testing thing works for you okay
the first is find the simplest most
cost-effective way to get started a lot
of us entrepreneurs will make
complicated plants and it has to be
perfect and it needs a lot of startup
capital and the problem is you spend 10
years working on this plan and you look
back and nothing has gotten done start
today start small the smallest simplest
easiest way to start and test and put
your time into it but not a lot of money
or no money if possible start something
small the smallest possible version
number two you text you start seeing if
it works is it working do you like it
are you getting money do you want to
keep doing this a lot of entrepreneurs
start a business and you realize this is
more work than I thought this is way
more time consuming than I thought this
isn't this isn't what I thought it was
going to be at all I don't want to do
this and you shut down I'd rather have
you shut down a small test project then
shut down a business that you've poured
your life seasons into and gone into
debt to get going so you test you test
on that small scale to make sure you
like it make sure you want to continue
doing it make sure it's making you some
money and then step three is expand
whatever is working blow it up expand if
your little online store is going well
invest some money into it make it grow
if you're having success renting a chair
from that nail salon maybe it's time to
open up your own shop but you know that
it's going to work you have a high
degree of success that it's going to
work because you've tested it so follow
those three things again quickly number
one find the smallest cheapest most
often cost effective way to get started
number two tests see if you like it or
not see what
working and number three expand on
things that are that are working or
doing well I know it's hard and I know
as entrepreneurs we like to dream big
it's good you should dream big you
should want to change the world you
should have a passion for what you're
doing you should want to build something
amazing to give yourself the best chance
of getting there you need to start small
start small start cheap do something
take action and build up from there I
guarantee it's the best way to reach
your goal because I don't want you to
invest tons of time money effort dollars
into the wrong path and you end up five
years later having to go back and get
another job living your life full of
regret that you couldn't make your dream
happen okay it's all possible start
small and test believe thanks for the
great question mo for everybody watching
if you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below make sure to do more for
you and I want to hear what you have to
think what do you think about this video
please leave a comment underneath and if
you have a question for your own company
let me know i'll make a video apart for
you thank you guys will see you soon
you